اعلنت وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه عن استشهاد
سيده فلسطينيه واصابه شخص اخر جراء اطلاق
قوه الاحتلال للاسرائيلي النيران على
سياره في بلده بيتونيا غرب رام الله فجر
اليوم ودعى جيش الاحتلال ان السياره التي
كانت تستقلها السيده قد اقتربت من ثلاثه
جنود اشتبهوا في انها تحاول دهسهم واطلقوا
النار باتجاهها
وكانت قوه عسكريه قد اقتحمت بلده بيتونيا
فجر اليوم واعتقلت عددا من الاشخاص
ونشر اي دكتور
اعتقلت قوات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي الثاني
عشر مواطنا فلسطينيا في انحاء مختلفه من
الضفه الغربيه ليله الماضيه وافد نادي
الاسير الفلسطيني ان اربعه من المعتقلين
من بلده بيتونيا غرب رام الله حيث قتل
جنود الاحتلال او قتل جنود الاحتلال سيده
فلسطينيه واصب شخص اخر بجروح فجر اليوم
بينما ينحدر باقي المعتقلين من مدينه
حلحول شمال الخليل والقدس المحتله حيث
دهمت قوه عسكريه كبيره هذه المناطق
واقتحمت المنازل واقتادت المعتقلين الى
معسكرتنا لتحقيق معهم بتهمه مقاومه
الاحتلال
جرافات الاحتلال الاسرائيلي صباح هذا
اليوم 3 منازل في قريه المنيا جنوب بيت
لحم في الضفه الغربيه وذكر شهود عيان ان
القوات من الجيش الاحتلال اقتحمت القريه
بصحبه جرافات الهدم وحصرت المنازل الثلاثه
التي تضم اكثر من طابق اشارت في عمليه
الهدم بذريعه البناء بدون ترخيص
من بيتونيا غربيه
جيفارا ضعينا اكثر في المشهد هناك في هذه
القريه مع ما حدث من اعتقالات وايضا قتل
هذه السيده الفلسطينيه
حسب وصف شهود العيان والمقاطع الصواريه
ومقاطع الفيديو التي التقطت من قبل
الكاميرات المثبته هنا لبعض المحال
التجاريه فانها عمليه اعدام ميداني نفذت
مع سبق الاصرار والترصد ما حدث بالتحديد
ان السياره كان بها شاب وايه سيده
فلسطينيه كان في السياره من ذلك الشارع
همم عندما همم تم رؤيه جنود الاحتلال
حوالي الالتفات والعوده الى منطقه اخرى
ولكن ما حدث هنا شهود العيان وايضا
المصادر الطبيه كان هنا بالتحديد عند هذه
السيارات جنود الاحتلال وايضا في هذه
الزاويه الثانيه ايضا عدد من الجنود وايضا
من الشارع في الاعلى اذا نتحدث عن ثلاثه
مواقع تم اطلاق النار منها على هذه
على الاقل 10 رصاصات اصابت السياره السيده
الشهيده هي سناء الطلاب البالغه من العمر
19 عاما وفقه وزاره الصحه الفلسطينيه هنا
وفق ما اكده الشهود العيان وايضا مصادر
هنا كانت جريمه هذه ااه ملابس السيده
الشهيده نرى هنا همم بعض من اثار الرصاص
الذي اطلق عليها وفقا مقاطع الفيديو وايضا
شهود العيان الذين يسكنون هنا بالقرب من
هذا الموقع اكدوا بان جنود الاحتلال قاموا
بانزال الشاب من السياره وهو جريح رغم انه
كان يرفع يديه الى اعلى اطلقوا النار عليه
في منطقه اليد والكتف والشهيد رغم علم
جنود الاحتلال بانها استشهدت قاموا
بتجريدها بالكامل من معظم ملابسها ومن ثم
ابلاغ
اا الارتباط الفلسطيني وتم اعتقال بالطبع
الشاب والشهيده ونقلهما الى معسكر عوفر
الاسرائيلي القريب من هنا ومن ثم ابلاغ
الهلال الاحمر الفلسطيني بوجود شهيده
وجريحه تم الافراج عن الجثمان وايضا عن
الشامهما الان في مجمع فلسطين الطبي هنا
في مدينه رام الله اذا وفق شهود العيان
كما ذكرنا نحن نتحدث عن اكده لنا وايضا
المصادر الطبيه نتحدثون عن عمليه اعدام
ميداني هذه العمليه كانت في خضام حمله
اعتقالات ينفذها جنود الاحتلال هنا في
المنطقه على الاقل اربعه فلسطينيين
اعتقلوا من هذا الحي تحديدا في بلده
بيتونيا في رام الله وبالتالي هناك شعور
الان لدى الفلسطينيين ان كل من يتحرك على
الارض هو معرض لاطلاق النار كانت الساعه
تقريبا الرابعه فجرا لم يكن هناك شيء في
الارض الجنود كانوا بالطبع بمتخفون تماما
لانه يخطفون خلف السيارات لم يتم اطلاق اي
طلقه تحذيريه وفق شهود العيان هم فجاه
سمعوا صوت همم كثيف لاطلاق النار شاهدوا
السياره شاهدوا عمليه انزال الشاب وتجريده
من الملابس وايضا الشهيده من معظم ملك
طبعا الان تجرى التحضيرات ل همم الجنازه
ولكن ذلك ياتي ايضا في استمرار حملات
الاعتقال الليليه نتحدث عن اثني عشر
معتقلا فلسطينيا ذكرنا من بينهم اربع هنا
من بلده بيتونيا وهمم هناك اعتقالات في
القدس المحتل من بينهم
ابناء لهم
البديري مراسله الجزيره كنت معنا من
بيتونيا غربيه رام الله شكرا لك